now during all of this this ecstasy
dealing and running around how old were
you and how much money were you making
at this time okay so I started the stock
market when I was 16 borrowed 50 pounds
off my name which was about 70 80
dollars back then and doubled there and
that was a big deal to me when I got to
America after Business Studies at uni I
arrived only with my student credit
cards didn't have a work visa but I
fully intended to conquer the world I'm
just out of uni I've watched that movie
Wall Street greed is good and that was
my motto so nothing was gonna stop me
work visa wasn't even the consideration
at a printing set ready and Mahan
it was it was mentoring meal and setting
back then we're ready to print a visa
into my passport if necessary so first
couple of years it was Commission only
and I'm new to telesales
and I'm really not money on my shoe
credit cards down to living off cheese
and toast and bananas worry don't we
have to come home but five years in I'm
the top guy in the office grossing half
a million a year got me on secretary
cold callers I end up with enough money
to retain that's what I did and I stuck
that into technology shares and they
show up during the.com bubble and that's
how I became a millionaire so the sad
thing is I didn't even need to begin a
fault in the drugs but it was all
ego-driven I've written about Escobar
and his brother said to him when he was
worth billions why don't we just buy our
own Island kickback we won't get
arrested we won't get killed by Rivals
and Escobar's like I'm running this
multi-billion dollar business I decide
who the President of Colombia is I've
got tens of thousands of people working
for me you want me to kick back on some
Island you know in a deck chair sipping
a cocktail they what my point being is
addiction to the lifestyle is more
powerful than addiction to the drugs
an addiction to the fast cash you know I
was a shy anxious student in this
country before I went out there I almost
got beat to death by some drunks when it
was years later in therapy I learned to
go deep inside myself and address some
of the root causes of what I'd done
and I was taking ecstasy and speed
because I had social anxiety people saw
this wild and crazy party animal who
once got off the drugs
I was this reserved person again so you
asked about money but it was more fueled
by the mental addiction to being the man
living in a million dollar house on the
side of a mountain swimming pool jacuzzi
you know my wife yeah she'd done a
university stuff but she was also doing
a lesbian internet porn
when you're a testosterone guy in your
20s this is what you aspire to why I see
the error of my ways now and I'm also
going to schools and speak to kids and
dissuade them from doing the crazy stuff
I did
Wow so you were already making millions
of dollars before you even entered this
drug world yes I bought one shares him
one company a stock it was called
Pacific satellite nonsense nonsense ray
an Indonesian telecom company and I
bought them around five dollars sure in
the late 1990s and during the peak of
the dot-com bubble that one alone hit 50
I had multiple positions like that in
satellite in tech and telecoms Wow I'd
wake up send my computer on and I'd be
up some days like a hundred grand yeah
that's unbelievable and that this was
all during the dot-com bubble Nicky said
join the bubble yeah so once you got
into dealing ecstasy and and making lots
more money dealing ecstasy you said you
were getting it from Holland is that
correct okay so in the beginning I was
just throwing house parties and showing
off on buying drugs and give
away for free and that was when I was
still working as a stockbroker my best
friend from childhood Wildman came over
and he just his place where he stayed
just became a permanent party house
and it's through him I met a lot of the
characters that became my business
partners later on from various mafias
and we realized we could only get a
hundred pills from the local dealers and
I'm tweaking um now I'm thinking all
right do I want to keep working the
stock market these long hours or should
I apply my business studies knowledge to
running an ecstasy importation business
in the beginning articles that la found
out the local dealers were getting them
out of LA first time I went out there by
a thousand pills whatever it was I took
Wildman I took to Cruz we had two cars
and we're parked on the street in some
area of Hollywood and we're waiting for
this guy he's not even home so I'm
thinking you know is this a setup the
police watching his house this guy am I
gonna go into money and he's gonna rob
me I went in the house on my own when we
saw him arrive and he was like a surfer
gangster dude and he had these
characters with him like out of Point
Break that movie yeah so I go in I'm
[ __ ] myself basically I've never
done anything at this level before this
is quite heavy for me at this point in
my life I tell him I've got the money
was the pills he goes all right I'll go
and get him I'm thinking he's gonna go
back in the room come out with a gun
just take my money off me could have
been done as easy as that but he comes
out with the biggest bag of pills I've
ever seen in my life and I say do you
mind if I took that try one first
because I knew the taste of ecstasy says
do you want a drink I said no I'm just
gonna chew it because I know what a good
ecstasy tastes like chewed it it tasted
good we did the deal I'm just dancing in
my car all the way back to Arizona and
those pills through wild man's apartment
in Tempe Arizona all those pills went
within a weekend then I realized okay
ecstasy is a scarce commodity in Arizona
it's gone for 25-30 dollars in the clubs
now this is definitely something I could
make money off and have fun but because
of that decision I lost absolutely
everything so I built up an organization
from the over a hundred people arrested
with me but I had about over 200 working
for me at the peak event and the LA guys
could get you know up to five thousand
pills at a time and it just wasn't doing
it anymore because demand was so high
I've got this vertically integrated
operation now we're by I'm throwing
raves I've got a rave clothing music
store got all this money laundering
stuff going home and so I couldn't leave
the country because I was an illegal
alien I got married three times but
never they never lasted long enough for
me to get my green card so I had to send
people out to Holland with testing kits
from a website called dance safe so a
good ecstasy pill usually like a beige
pressured be hundred 125 milligrams of
MDMA and clay and when you test it in
this kit it changes this thing's like a
purple blue color so you know I was also
worth it if I'm bringing bulk pills back
to the states if there's some kind of
toxic substance in them you know people
could potentially die
[Laughter]